this year rodon i mean personally for
him career era of 4.14 coming into the
season
again he's league average even 100 era
plus over 500 innings but he comes back
rejuvenated a 1.27 era in 42 plus
innings
you're not going to see a better pitch
here than you would have on that first
pitch for me when you know it's going to
be a group fastball
a little bouncer to short
danny mendick up and throwing that's
danny mendic yes at shortstop tim
anderson getting the day off here's
dylan carlson center fielder but the
hard hit is there and he's kind of been
everything
strikeout there for odon gets his first
of the day in the first inning he had 13
strikeouts against the yankees in just
six innings his last start wow like come
on yeah that's cool that's not what an
empire should be doing you're right pay
off pitch and he lost to me
working a walk paul goldschmidt gets
first yeah that's been great yeah lemay
who got better as a year one on because
he physically stayed healthy all year
long and there's a look at john gant
6'4 right-hander 28 years old he was
drafted by the mets in 2011. traded to
the braves then traded to the cardinals
in 2016. he walks a lot of guys keeps
the ball in the yard right he's an a
whole round low home run rate so he's
surviving but i know what you're saying
it's unlikely he will flourish with that
skill set fly ball right field
and glove nicely
lane thomas out in right field
he gave that bald ride i mean looked
like he reached for it but got good
barrel
lost in four straight
eating is on he has not touched 90 miles
an hour to start this game he's 95 96 in
the bullpen two years ago there he goes
he could eat taking off and
he's in
i missed again and another walk back to
back walks brave steps in reigning
american league mvp he's got two on one
out
swinging right away gant gloves it
oh no he throws it away couldn't find
second base and then the bases are still
loaded here's your mean mercedes with
the bases loaded one out o'brien went
after the first pitch
mercedes does as well and stays up
into left field
and justin williams with the throw to
the plate
oh wow they got him
oh there's some defense
wow justin williams up and throwing
beautifully done let's take a look at
this play now in left field justin
williams on the line drive up throwing
91 miles an hour that's a beautiful
throw up a little up on the first base
line too but brought back nicely
by kisner behind the plate carlos rodon
comes back second inning he just has
like the largest gap in baseball which
is why it's so interesting
wow fooled him there strikes out sosa
laying thomas to 1-2
struck him out
back to work as carlos rodon max moroff
steps up for the cardinals town is full
now
they struck him out rodon another k is
justin williams by the way it's one and
two to him like you don't want to be a
power hitter well we don't much time to
discuss that because carlos rodon has
six strikeouts and then he snaps this
nasty slider curveball that starts wow
in the same exact tunnel that you were
so late on you have no shot at that
speaking of second base tommy edmond
lead off hitter steps in he said these
guys have to swing edmond swings there
hits that ball hard into left field and
look at that
big power tommy edmund with a solo home
run he was all over that pitch change up
talking about being on time
for this particular pitch and it looked
like a chain job change up middle man
it's his third best pitch right and
edmond with that's the hardest hit ball
for edmond this season just over 112
miles per hour 436 it's serious you know
he crushed that and that was earned you
know that changeup was not at risk from
an effective velocity perspective so
good hitting right here
he's not getting near the zone four
pitches
abreu takes his base
and it will set up the confrontation
your mean mercedes
versus john gann
by the way gant uh
his opponents batters uh the opponents
are over six with the bases loaded two
and two now
[Applause]
and staying playable
paul goldschmidt is there and john get
escapes
again and gets through still one nothing
second bases loaded big spot for
euromean mercedes lori garcia steps up
with two outs in what has been a quiet
calm inning for john gann
hit that ball hard and face it you spoke
way too soon the right field now now now
it gets interesting here's danny mendick
shortstop it wasn't just about third
time it was about like changes in his oh
and he struck him out look at that
painting on the outside part as dan
plisack would say stepping off the mound
like he stepped into a bucket of sassy
one-nothing cardinals lane thomas let's
do up feeling pretty good on the mound
but effective velocity actually checks
out the metrics and see if he's checking
the boxes another strikeout well seven
k's now for carlos rodon max morph gets
up here he had guys off balance pulling
the string on guys he was poised and
masterful another strikeout
eight strikeouts now for carlos rodon
and here's justin williams i just like
the way he stood out like a gunslinger
in left field
the other look is good right there 86
rodon strikes out the side he's got nine
strikeouts two on and two outs
and does anybody want to go to the pen
now still with him
your mean mercedes is next and he
handled mercedes pretty well last time
up
ground ball third base
and the cardinals get out of it max
moroff goes short way it brings up paul
goldschmidt
the one and two struck out
last pitch 99 that 100. welcome back to
chicago michael kopeck is in carlos
rodon
is done um
slightly surprised at 94 pitches he went
six
two two
oh
hope goes down i think he hurt himself
and the ball skied to third base makes
the play let's check in with kopeck
comes limping off didn't see if he
caught his spike we'll check in but he
gets through on the fly ball and it's
still a one-nothing ball game gallegos
comes on
you've got two on tight game one-nothing
ball game what are they looking at here
joe west is over to check in on gallegos
he was signaling on the hat yeah
oh he threw him out
whoa
joe west
throws out gallegos they're taking a hat
now they're gonna send it to the league
office oh my goodness they have
confiscated evidence jogging in you can
see it on the bill of the cap joe west
the senior man to everyone in the
history of the game he said oh i had it
on my forearm now i have it on my cap
oh
[ __ ] all right that's around the whole
time oh my goodness so came over came
over and said something and right after
that
i want to know what schultz said there
so gaia goes to stay they change the hat
and now shilt is gone healthy numbers
there for mercedes two on two
wow
big strikeout two outs for aaron bumper
tommy edmond who has the home run back
in the second inning that is the one run
in this ball game
oh wow
wow wow wow again
no doubt tommy edmond two home runs it's
two nothing well he's locked in on that
my goodness that ball was absolutely
crushed i think it was a hanging slider
i'm gonna call that a fine piece of
hitting doesn't edmond has cut his
strikeout rate by half a good
drives in a run
boltzmann coming in aronato is he coming
around he's coming around on billy
hamilton through the plate
and he got it in cardinals breaking this
open four nothing now in the night oh
and two to jose abreu
struck him out
up and in with the heat
and alex reyes the a squad bullpen and
john gant
shut out the chicago white sox and
salvage this series they avert the
three-game sweep